Wasser ist gleich Wasser und Eis ist
gleich Eis mal abgesehen von der Frage
ob Schoko oder Vanille
es gibt zig verschiedene Arten wie
Wasser in der freien Wildbahn und vor
allem in den unendlichen Weiten des
Universums vorkommt jetzt haben forschen
eine weitere Eisform entdeckt die alles
auf den Kopf stellt MDA warum ist das
neue Eis bei der Erforschung des
Weltraums helfen könnte genau das
erfahrt ihr jetzt
[Musik]
dr Watson wurde für den Grimma Online
Award nominiert und wir sind mega happy
und freuen uns unglaublich was das für
eine Ehre ist doch mit so vielen coolen
anderen Formaten zusammen nominiert zu
sein ob wir tatsächlich gewonnen haben
dass erfahren wir erst am 15 Juni aber
bis dahin gibt es noch ein Publikum
Voting wo ihr tatsächlich mit abstimmen
könnt wer das beste Online Format hat
wenn ihr uns als unterstützen wollt dann
geht gerne auf Grimme - online -
award.de schaut nach welches ist das
beste Online-Angebot ist stimmt dafür ab
wir freuen uns sehr vielen Dank für eure
Unterstützung das ganz normale Wasser
das jeden Tag aus unserem Hand kommt ist
physikalisch und chemisch gesprochen
mega seltsam es zeigt 70 Abweichungen
vom normalen Verhalten von Flüssigkeiten
und viele dieser Anomalien können wir
bis heute nicht erklären es gibt zum
Beispiel Eis das halb so heiß ist wie
unsere Sonne oder schwarzes Eis das
trotzdem nur aus Wassermolekülen besteht
und auch unter weniger krassen
Bedingungen macht Wasser was es will
anständige Flüssigkeiten ziehen sich zum
Beispiel immer weiter zusammen je kälter
sie werden was Wasser macht es nicht bis
4 Grad Celsius macht es mit aber danach
dehnt es sich wieder aus in gewisser
Weise ist das ein Glück denn so schwimmt
Eis oben unsere Fische hätten sonst im
Winter ein echtes Problem kurzum es gibt
nicht einfach nur Wasser es gibt sich
Formen von Wasser ein Grund dafür dass
es ständig aus der Reihe der
chemikalientanz ist vermutlich seine
Kontaktfreudigkeit es hat vier chemische
Haken mit denen es sich an andere
andocken kann bei unserem normalen
flüssigen Wasser ändert es mehrmals die
Sekunde sein Beziehungsstatus so ist es
ständig in Bewegung und ziemlich
veränderbar
in dem neuen Experiment haben forschende
jetzt etwas getan was erstmal komisch
klingt sie haben Eis in einen Behälter
mit Metallkugeln gepackt auf -200°c
gekühlt und dann heftig geschüttelt in
der Forschung heißt diese Prozedur
allmilling bei mir zu Hause heißt das
Cocktails machen
herauskamen nicht Slush Eis sondern eine
ganz neue Form von Eis Medium dancerty
Amorphis eyes also Amorphis Eis mit
einer mittleren Dichte Amorphis Eis oder
auch ungeordnetes Eis heißt dass die
chemische Struktur nicht kristallin ist
es entsteht normalerweise wenn Wasser so
schnell gefriert dass die Moleküle keine
Zeit haben sich zu einem Gitter zu
ordnen hier auf der Erde ist es sehr
selten aber im All die vorwiegende
Eisform und hier steckt vielleicht auch
der Grund warum die Forschenden so ein
seltsames Experiment gemacht haben denn
ähnliche Bedingungen wie in dem
Metallkugel Container könnten auf
eismonten im äußeren Solarsystem
beherrschen hier wirken die
Gezeitenkräfte von Jupiter Saturn und
anderen Gasriesen so stark dass im
Inneren solcher Monde wahrscheinlich
ganz schön viel gedrückt und geschoben
wird ähnlich wie in einem Behälter mit
herumwirbelnden Metallkugeln also was
kann denn jetzt unser Eis mit
Schleudertrauma es kann vor allem eins
bisherige Annahmen über Wasser in Frage
stellen denn vom normalen kristallinen
Eis sind ungefähr 20 Arten bekannt vom
amorphen nur zwei eines mit hoher Dichte
und eines mit niedriger Dichte immer im
Vergleich zu normalem Wasser tatsächlich
gibt es überhaupt kein Eis mit der
gleichen dichte wie Wasser egal ob
amorph oder nicht man dachte das ist
dazwischen eben einfach nichts gäbe bis
die Forschenden ihren Shaker öffneten
und das neue Eis fanden denn das hat
fast genau die Dichte von normalem
Wasser
so what könnte man jetzt sagen schön
eine Nummer 21 für das Eis aber nicht
für die Wissenschaft denn es zeigt den
Forschenden dass sie ihre Annahmen noch
mal überdenken müssen auch das ist eine
super wichtige Erkenntnis aber das ist
noch nicht alles das neue Wasser hat
noch eine zweite Überraschung auf Lager
als die Forschenden den Druck wieder
reduzierten und das Eis langsam
erhitzten setzte es plötzlich eine große
Menge Energie frei so viel dass das
Forscherteam vermutet das ist Erdbeben
auf besagten Monden verursachen könnte
naja Eisleben wenn man jetzt ganz genau
sein will z.B auf dem Mond Europa ist
die Beschaffenheit der Eiskruste noch
lange nicht verstanden genauso wenig wie
sein Innenleben doch das soll sich bald
ändern die NASA und europäische Arbeiter
wollen demnächst dort vorbei fliegen
juice der Explorer der Isar ist dieses
Frühjahr erfolgreich gestartet und da
ist es super hilfreich wenn wir hier auf
der Erde mit einem womöglich ähnlichen
Material wie dort oben weitere Versuche
durchführen können
und vielleicht sind Amor vereissorten
sogar ein Schlüssel um die Anomalien von
flüssigem Wasser zu erklären apropos
flüssiges Wasser wir wurden von r-up
kontaktiert die das Wasser trinken
revolutionieren wollen aber warte mal
war das nicht das Startup vom rennenden
Frank Thelen und war das nicht mega
unnachhaltig nun genau das haben wir uns
auch gefragt und das Unternehmen mal
genauer unter die Lupe genommen so wie
wir das mit allen potenziellen Sponsoren
dieses Kanals hier machen also was ist
dran das Prinzip von aerob ist
eigentlich erstmal ganz simpel man füllt
normales Leitungswasser in so eine
Flasche hier und mit geruchskapseln
sogenannten aromaports fügt man dann
Geschmack hinzu und wissenschaftlich
gesehen funktioniert das Geschmacks und
Geruchssinn sind miteinander verbunden
und wenn wir etwas riechen wären wir z.B
Wasser im Mund haben dann schmeckt das
Wasser dadurch anders und im
Selbstexperiment muss ich sagen
ja schmeckt ein bisschen so wie
Mineralwasser mit Geschmack es ist nicht
wirklich Cola oder Orangensaft aber es
schmeckt ein bisschen nachdem was es
sein soll würde ich jetzt sagen dafür
ist es deutlich gesünder logischerweise
ist normales Wasser Zucker BPA und
kalorienfrei geil aber ist das ganze
auch nachhaltig nun die Pots bestehen
aus Plastik und halten für ca 5 Liter
Wasser sind aber immerhin recyclebar
hergestellt werden die Kapseln
inzwischen in Holland die
Edelstahlflasche selber kommt aktuell
noch aus China soll aber bald in der EU
hergestellt werden und auch die
Herstellung der tritanflasche wurde
schon nach Österreich geholt das Startup
gibt sich also Mühe und rechnet selber
vor wenn man Wasser sonst aus
Einwegflaschen trinken würde dann spart
man mit den Potts bis zu 88% Plastik ein
gut man könnte auch einfach direkt
Leitungswasser trinken da vielleicht ein
Zitrone reinquetschen und 100% Plastik
einsparen und das stimmt auch aber
seitlich wie viele Menschen da draußen
machen das wirklich und wie viele kaufen
sich jeden Tag Cola oder Wasser mit
Geschmack in der Plastikflasche genau
das sind die Leute die aeropt gerne
bekehren möchte wenn ihr euch das ganze
auch mal anschauen und selbst
ausprobieren wollt dann klick auf den
Link unten in der Beschreibung bei mir
und jetzt kommen wir mal zu meiner
persönlichen Meinung hat erop definitiv
dazu geführt dass ich deutlich mehr
Wasser trinke als vorher was bestimmt
auch an der tatsächlich schick designten
und hochwertigen Flasche liegt da hätte
Frank Thelen eigentlich gar nicht
wegrennen müssen wir halten euch hier
natürlich auf dem Laufenden sobald es
weitere Erkenntnisse über das neue Eis
oder die eismonde gibt abonniert dafür
gerne den Kanal um das sich zu verpassen
und in der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr euch
hier gerne anschauen wie all unsere
Elemente auch Wasser am Anfang des
Universums entstanden sind bis dahin
bleibt neugierig euer Cedric